d'ici deux jours cette clinique médicale
ne recevra plus de patients sur place
nous sommes en train de fermer les
portes pour que les gens utilisent la
téléconsultation à la place de venir
physiquement sur place les bureaux de
consultation sont déjà vides
médecins et infirmières ont déménagé à
un autre étage et consultent leurs
patients au téléphone un chambardement
provoquée par la coved 19 et les
craintes liées au manque de masques de
protection
j'ai rien on ne veut pas que notre
personnage sous exposé m rhénus si c'est
possible qu'on ne se voit pas demain
bureau sept médecins a adopté le travail
téléphonique dès le début de la crise en
février
les gens sont ravis alors j'ai appelé
systématiquement là depuis cinq jours
tous mes patients leur disant ne venait
pas je vais vous faire une consultation
téléphonique et on a tout réglé sur une
soixantaine de cas sauf deux personnes
une bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement
québécois qui souhaitait de toute façon
à accélérer le virage vers la
télémédecine oui nous plonger dans
l'action
cette application conçue pour la
télémédecine permet même une
conversation vidéo sécurisé avec le
patient
pour la psychiatre à mal abdel baqi il
est désormais possible de suivre 80% des
patients à distance votre hygiène à
négliger
vous avez là avec la pandémie on
accélère le déploiement de ce système
dans tous les départements
en fait il ya 60% des équipes cliniques
qui sont en train de déployer la
téléconsultation à l'heure actuelle et
ça ne fait que dix jours dans font qu'on
est au coeur de la crise
la crise provoque clairement une
profonde transformation des pratiques
j'espère qu'elle a su de la crise on va
pouvoir continuer gens qui pourraient
effectivement changé à jamais le réseau
de la santé
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal